Hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 17 of my road to one bill series.
Today we're going to start off by doing
a couple quests. I'm going to do big
chompy bird hunting and then zer flesh
eater. Uh we need this for moneymaking
method I'm going to use. Uh but yeah,
let's get started. All right, so we're
starting off with big bird chompy
hunting. Chompy big bird hunting. You
know that quest. Uh the one where you
got to inflate a frog with uh the uh
kind of inflatable drum thing. I don't
know. That thing in my right top right
corner of my inventory. Uh, but yeah,
it's pretty easy quest. And uh, there we
go. Two quest points and 262 fletching.
Uh, not that big a deal, but we mainly
just need it for a prerequisite. So,
we're going to start Zer flesh eating
next. All right, so we're on to Zer
Flesh Eater. Uh, we're just sketching a
little portrait of this gnome dude here
sitting in the bed and uh, taking some
stat damage, which is so annoying. Those
fives are actually neg five to a random
stat. So, my stats are slowly draining.
Uh, which is kind of hilarious. I've
never even seen that before. All right,
so we're at this point in the quest
where we've unlocked the money-making
method I wanted. If you didn't see my
video, it was um making flighted arrows
and you need to shop unlock to buy the
achy logs. Uh so you can see we can buy
100. Easy to do. And we're just on to
the boss of the quest. Kind of funny.
His name is just Slash Bash. Not the
most original, but also not the
strongest either. Uh but we'll kill him
and then finish up the quest. All right,
there we go. The quest is complete. Um,
I know this isn't completely related to
uh, Lunar Diplomacy or anything, but I
like to do a couple quests every episode
just to mix things up a bit. And uh,
those are the ones I picked. On a side
note, look how much money you get for
finishing the quest. Almost 70k just in
ogre bones. Crazy. So, like I said, my
next goal is Lunar Diplomacy. So, for
that, we need 60 mining. Uh, we're just
about to hit 50. So, this is very slow
scale, but we're going to get at least
60 mining this episode, but we're going
to mix it up with some other things so
it's not the most boring that
you've ever seen. Uh, but there's 50
mining. Oh my god, that's a lot of blue
feathers. Uh, good job to Vas Jalite for
acquiring 100k blue feathers. That is
impressive, man. Thank you very much for
that uh generous donation. All right, so
we actually finished up another run of
crops and by that I mean we finished up
all the seeds we had. So we have 315
um
Renars in our bank which equates to
about 2 mil probably a mill of that in
profit. So pretty nice. So the Renar
sold off pretty quickly and um we're
going to take that money out. Now what
we're going to do with it is uh we're
going to take the rest of our money. So
we have about 15 mil and we're going to
invest in some items from the stonemason
shop. Pretty easy way to make money with
very low requirements. And uh yeah, I'll
show you what it is. So, what we're
going to be buying is the gold leaf and
possibly the marble block. Now, the gold
leaf sell on the Grand Exchange for 135k
and they buy here for 130. Now, the
marble blocks by for 325k, I think, from
here. Yeah, and they sell for 330 on the
Grand Exchange. So, what we're going to
do is we're going to buy one in each
world, hop to the next world, and then
just keep doing that till our money's uh
been all spent. It won't honestly take
very long, probably only like 5 or 10
minutes to spend all that 15 mil.
They're pretty expensive, uh, but it'll
be easy to do. And then we just wait for
them to sell while we're mining. All
right, so we bought out 29 marble blocks
and 29 gold leaves. We're just going to
buy another one to check. So yeah, buys
for 330. So we're going to sell it for
uh for 329. Um, and the same on the gold
leaf. And the gold leaf uh is going to
buy for 134,900.
So we're going to sell both of those for
a 5k profit. That is 60 items in total
roughly uh at 5k each. That is 300k in
profit for just 5 or 10 minutes work.
So, pretty nice. And there is level 55
mining. Mining levels are coming much
lower now, but we're making good
progress towards getting the uh gem bag
or the coal bag. Not decided yet, but
I'm kind of leaning towards the coal
bag. Uh cuz I think I might actually use
it a bit more. All right, the item sold
pretty quickly. And that is a nice 295k
in profit. Pretty good for only uh 5 or
10 minutes work. So, we're definitely
going to take the money and go reinvest
in more of these items cuz this is just
easy money and I can just do it on the
side while I'm mining. Uh, which is kind
of nice. So, we'll go ahead and buy some
more. We're back at the Celligrim
Stonemason shop. Uh, now the gold leaf
is definitely much better value. It is
the same margin except a third of the
cost. So, if you don't have a big cash
stack, uh, buying the gold leaf out is
definitely the best idea. But, I'm lazy
and it's twice as slow to buy the items
uh, if you're just going for one of
them. All right, so we're just selling
off the gold leaf again, as well as the
marble blocks. We got a little bit more
this time. Uh, so about 66 items, which
will be a little over 300k profit, which
I'm super happy about. And, uh, we'll
get back to mining. And there is another
4700 blue feathers. Thank you very much
uh to uh, HR Swifty. Appreciate, man.
All right, so we mostly sold off all the
items again. That is going to be another
300k in profit. Pretty happy with that.
Um, the gold leaves are still selling
for about a 5k profit, which is pretty
nice. And, uh, we'll go back and buy
some more, I think. Uh, we still haven't
gotten the mining level cuz they're
buying and selling so quickly. Uh, but
easy money. This is road to one bill,
not road to 99 mining. So, got to get
our priorities straight. All right, so
this time I went solely for the leaves.
Took a lot longer, but we managed to get
90 gold leaves. And that is going to be
450k in profit, which is going to be
pretty awesome. All right, there we are.
are back at the good old motherload
mine. There is 56 mining. Oh, this is so
slow. Uh, but we are getting pretty
close to having the coal bag, which is
always a little motivating. All right,
so we sold off our gold leaves. Um, we
had to drop the price a little bit on
some of them. And then we decided to
just put a buy offer in cuz I actually
had a 7k margin on an item like this. I
thought it was going to be a great flip.
Um, and I know I said it wouldn't do a
lot of flipping, but I'm not purposely
not doing it. Uh, so we just decide to
throw a flip in there. We only get eight
of them. Um, but that's still after all
said and done, after the 90 leaves were
sold, about 400k in profit. And it
probably took us about 20 minutes to buy
the leaves. So, really good and uh very
easy to do. Hey guys, you're in the
video. I have no idea why this clip's in
here. And I took me like 5 minutes to
realize what's going on. Anyway, we're
just buying golden leaves. Uh, filler
filler filler. Enjoy. All right, so we
have another 118 gold leaves to sell.
That is going to be close to 600k in
profit. Uh the leaves are still 135, so
that's still 5k in profit on each one of
those. Going to give us close to 600k,
which I'm pretty excited for. Um we're
still working on the mining, but um it's
so exciting making money and who needs
mining. All right, we're going to a 99
party in Catherby. Uh for someone in the
CC who just got 99 fletching. Uh and
they're all like, "Oh, you need to bring
some stuff to drop." And I'm like,
"Okay, uh, we'll get some myithil maces
cuz you know, everyone wants Myithil
mazes." And, uh, we'll get some good
stuff. Don't worry. It's actually a lot
more fun dropping stuff just waiting and
wondering who's going to pick it up. Uh,
it's so obvious to you where everything
is, but it's funny watching everyone
flounder around. And, uh, yeah, the
myithal mazes weren't as big a hit. Um,
people seem to be digging these daggers
a little more. And, uh, we do have a
couple scimitars to drop as well. Oh
man, scimitar too valuable to drop. Oh
wow, there's one there. And drop some
med helms here. And I'm going to drop
these right under people and see if they
actually get it. All right, right under
this guy. And boom. Don't move, buddy.
Stay there. And own 3R38 coming in with
128k blue feathers. Oh my god. How are
you guys even buying all these? Who's
supplying the feathers here to be
honest? Um, but anyway, thanks again,
guys. Uh, we've made a huge progress, a
huge gains on our feather stack. Uh,
which is always nice. There is another
80 leaves coming in at a 4k margin on
each one. That is 320k. Another easy bit
of cash. Our stacks up to 16 mil now.
Uh, which I think is the highest it's
ever been. Uh, we're getting pretty
close to 20, which is going to be
awesome. All right, so we decided to
move back to the gold leaves and the
marble blocks cuz um we're spending a
lot more time doing this than we are
mining. Uh so we're going to go ahead
sell these off and uh still net like a
250k profit. Uh but we're going to spend
more time mining at least now. All
right, here's another mining level
coming up. I think this is going to be
57 or 58 mining. Um and
it is 57. Oh, we're about to hit another
mining level. At least when this gets
into the hopper. Anyway, uh there is 58
mining. Only two more levels and then we
can finally get the prerequisite for
learner diplomacy done. Um that is once
we get all the other prerequisites. This
one is just taking so long. Um but
anyway,
whatever. There's another 52 items from
the Stonemason shop sold. It's going to
be another uh 250k in profit, which I'm
pretty happy about. bringing our cash
back up to about 16.4 mil, uh, which I
think is the highest it's ever been.
There is another 42 items or 43, sorry,
from the Stonemason shop, giving us
another 250k in profit. And now we're
going to try something else I have not
actually tried before, and that is
buying uh death runes from the Mage of
Zamarak. Uh, it's a little risky cuz
it's in the wilderness, but we'll give
it a shot. All right, so uh we're
starting off just buying the runes from
uh this guy's shop. Uh the margin is
pretty good because death runes are up
to 230 right now. Uh so we're going to
buy out all the runes we can and spend
the 1 mil and hopefully we don't die.
All right, we managed to acquire about
2500 death runes. Uh so we'll see how
much we actually made. This probably
only took me 10 minutes maximum,
probably less to be honest. And we'll
pop them into the GE. All right, so I
forgot we actually had some of the death
runes in our bank already. Uh so we
actually got 3.8k death runes. is that
we went back halfway because we're kind
of sketched about dying. And it is
sketchy cuz there are people running
nature runes or constantly running you
with skulls. So, you really need to have
a iron mentality to do that. But we
didn't die out. Some guys tried to
attack us, but it's not a big deal. It's
only level four wilderness. So, we
didn't really even come close to dying.
So, we're going to sell these off for
330 each, netting us about 260k. Only 10
minutes it took. So, pretty good. Might
try this again later. All right. So, the
death runes and the gold leaf have
totally sold. About 260k in profit from
the death runes. Another 100k in profit
from the gold leaves. I mean, it just
adds up, guys. I know it doesn't seem
like a lot in each chunk, but really the
amount of time I'm putting into each of
these, only 10 minutes really per method
or per activity. And uh I mean, I must
have done this at least five or six
times now. So, that's probably 1 to 2
million profit just randomly buying
items just while I'm waiting. And so a
little bit of ingenuity and uh thinking
can really net you a good profit. All
right, we're just about to hit 59 mining
now once we finally mine this last rock.
59 mining. Only one more level to go and
then we can finally be done with this
mini quest. And with this last ore, that
will give us 60 mining. There we go,
guys. 60 mining. That's the prerequisite
for Lunar Diplomacy done, as well as we
actually get into the mining guild. Uh,
so now I think we're going to pretty
much end the episode, but we'll go do a
recap of all the money we've made, what
our final cash is going to be, and
quickly look at our skills. After about
20 levels of Motherload mine, we got
about 3k coal, 600 gold ore, as well as
248 myth ore. Uh, so it's only worth
about 730k, so it's definitely not a lot
of money, but we mainly did this just so
we could AFK as opposed to power mining,
uh, which is 10 times worse. On top of
that, we have about 350 Renars uh from
farming and about 110 gold nuggets. And
we can't forget the blue feathers coming
in about 350k.
All right, so after we collect
everything, everything's been sold. We
are at 19 mil. Going to be very close to
20, it looks like. Yeah, 19.8.
And um yeah, so what would you guys uh
suggest I do with the gold nuggets?
Probably going to keep them for now
until I actually know for certain. I'm
leaning towards the coal bag. Uh but
what do you guys think? Uh any
particular opinion between the coal bag
and the gem bag or even the prospector's
outfit. Uh leave a comment down below.
Um so we're up to 350k feathers. Really
good uh show by everyone today. I got
over a couple hundredk feathers. And um
now for my stats. Only real change of
course was the mining levels up to 60
mining. And but next episode, I promise
we're going to finish off uh the
prerequisites for lunar diplomacy and
hopefully get the quest done. So, thanks
for watching, guys. I hope you enjoyed
and I will see you guys in the next
video.
[Music]